josy oui patron appelé moins 117 oss 117
ne vaut pas le meilleur
[Musique]
je vous répondrai oui ce serait de la
prétention
[Musique]
je vous répondrais non ça serait la
bêtise
hubert que savez vous de l'afrique
les africains sont joyeux sympathique il
danse bien très bonne analyse super je
compte sur vous aucun malentendu nos
amis voit du racisme partout le
président vous resterez à ces êtres
parfaits le temps d'enfiler mon costume
colonial blanc clair pourquoi c'est
clair
dans quelques jours je donne un bal
présidentielle au palais pour fêter
l'indépendance d'indépendance ou et on
m'a dit ça
117 je vous présente pour ssmi 1 117 et
fut le vrai l'unique la légende
sous les traits d'un joker toujours en
solo cette mission vous allez me l'a
menée tous les deux les rebelles veulent
balayer le président d'en bas un groupe
par mme bachmann in your browser
c'est pour ça que j'ai contre prince est
payé en main
y ait un hic de taille vous êtes une
femme est une femme présidente
je suis agent secret pas nourrice
[Musique]
c'est un quiproquo
tout est sous contrôle
c'est un peu fatigué mais enfin il va se
ressaisir
pas mal non
et là il a tout foutu en l'air puis à
8,6 et un plan il va falloir qu'ils
m'expliquent
j'ai un peu de mal à saisir la stratégie
chaque espèce la plus dangereuse soit
elle à son prédateur je suis leur
prédateur
est ou n'est plus bas la wii mais eux ne
savent pas
créé dans les alpes un attrayant 800 qui
reliait dubaï à paris au moins 300
passagers
tu as pu avoir accès aux données à 15 et
la trajectoire mais l'appareil a piqué
rapidement ça a été très brutal
les experts du bea ont été dépêchés sur
les lieux de l'accident pour tenter de
localiser les boîtes noires
maintenant je peux le soir de connaître
l'enchaînement exact c'est vraiment
c'est bon c'est exploitable
atténue le moteur dans le médium
concentrez vos sources qu'on entend
on va tenter
j'ai des doutes sur le crash
ya un problème avec la boîte noire
a été falsifiée savent a intérêt à avoir
raison
je comprends pas qu'on ait pu lui
confier l'enquêté n'a encore entendu des
sons fantôme
j'ai vu que vous aviez signalé des
preuves de gouverne sur le 800
ya eu un attentat des premiers à l'avoir
entendu que j'ai entendu c'est une
[ __ ] de suite d'incohérences en 30
minutes et la terre
la vérité sur le crash ne la connaît
c'est allé trop loin
ce que tu as fait tu l'as fait pour toi
tu prêt à marcher dessus pour prouver
tes délires
[Musique]
durant toute ma vie les dix anneaux ont
rendu ma famille puissante
et si tu veux qu'ils appartiennent plus
tard tu dois me prouver que tu es assez
fort pour les mériter
tu es le produit de tous ceux qui t'ont
précédé
tu est l'héritier de ta famille tu est
amer et que ça te plaise ou pas
tu es aussi ton père
j'ai dit à mes hommes qu'il n'arriverait
pas te tuer même s'il essayait
heureux d'avoir un récent
tu n'es qu'un criminel
1 tu as rien plus
ne me parlent jamais sur ce tout petit
j'ai voulu changer de nom
changer de vie
mais je ne pourrai jamais
échappé à son antre
ton fils
ne peut pas fuir ton passé
c'est ce que tu voulais
tu peux t'en sortir
bien sûr
walgren
et calmer
une bagarre
besoin le monde est ici leïla est
certes un bon
lee
might have a dream
police
m
smoby
tout ça
m
beaucoup
vous
mathieu cahn sa relaxe
[Musique]
nous avons un dicton sur as garde quand
on voit les oreilles du loup cédant ne
sont pas loin
c'est un piège
il mois il nous manipulent j'ai failli
faire avoir le kit moi aussi je les
aurais pas dû
voilà le topo
l'avarié en fuite tuno minuteur depuis
un moment
qu'on n'avons pas trouvé par nous mêmes
alors on a besoin d'un expert c'est moi
ce criminel peut être n'importe où
n'importe quand
la prudence s'impose tout ce que nous
ferons peut impacter le cours de
l'histoire vous comprenez ok ok
[Musique]
les quartiers du temps supervise le
moindre aspect de cette affaire
te fier à lui n'est pas une excellente
idée
aucun homme mauvais n'est totalement
mauvaise
[Musique]
et qu'aucun homme bon n'est totalement
bon
ça n'a rien à voir avec toi d'accord
quand y attendait
[Musique]
dire que je croyais bêtement
que vous pouvez être n'importe qui
puisqu'un bien
je devrais être protégé pas me sentir en
danger c'est presque insultant ou une
soeur red on jamais
[Musique]
g d'émission le produira pourtant ce pot
est ce que vous connaissez le bar autres
offres c'est son business et compagnie
oh je vois vraiment un vieux dégueulasse
ça floride a été saboté
le barreau a demandé une enquête discret
pour que les invités ne soient pas
importunées vous comprenez jean andreas
ne peut pas servir baisser le plat
je vais les cuisiner un nain la vérité
va jaillir d'elles mêmes
méthodes boulot
boulot
je suis là cela indépendamment jeu oui
c'est moi tenez voilà donc j'ai fait de
la barre
je soigne ou
deux matches aux avait dû tomber sur un
vieux rappelé mois sans pas moi abrous
oui je sens chez vous mais pas chez moi
laisse pas tranquille tout ce que j'ai
dit c'est qu'on pourra laisser tomber la
rando je parlais pas de nom en général
je parlais de la rando envie de faire en
sorte que notre couple and you are est
notre coupe va bien c'est quoi ça les
cloches d'une église
je me gâte ou
bienvenue dans notre village où vivent
nos zamis probablement un truc qui font
tourner tout le monde
est ce qu'on peut y aller maintenant
mois déjà
c'est comme si
on ne pouvait pas partir c'est la magie
on est dans une réalité de comédie
musicale sur saône avant tout le monde
[Musique]
et
il a tout construit prisonniers jusqu'à
ce qu'on trouve le vrai amour est ce que
tu crois que ce qu'on vise c'est une
véritable caisse que je me gâte on
considère comme le grand amour on n'en
sait rien laquelle deux voies envie de
traverser le pont avec moi j'ai tenté le
coup avec d'autres personnes
je vous fais tous les deux vous êtes en
versant tu comparer à vous je suis
paysanne badufle allons vite retrouver
vos chaussures
[Applaudissements]
mais quand c'est là pour toujours vous
allez laisser tomber comme ça on est
malin on arrive bien à sortir d'ikea
trouvera un moyen mais n'a pu y avoir un
glissement
[Musique]
je suis
[Applaudissements]
dans une comédie musicale il ya pas de
morts dans les comédies musicales
sauf oklahoma et carousel et south
pacific airways a history remercie
toutes les comédies musicales
[Musique]
d'après certains éléments les boîtes
jack in the box aurait à l'origine été
créé en france pour cacher des entités
mali
[Musique]
paris doit
dans nos esprits
[Musique]
bella et ses yeux matin
tu cites
il fixe des y sont connectés parquet
[Musique]
basket foot
celle ci
[Musique]
pour tous
c'est vrai qu'elle d'accord
ovni
[Musique]
et non
résultat
que non
à noter au divorce
[Musique]
m
décalé
mais moi
[Musique]